are you hoping to achieve
well we're hoping that the government
will listen to this that they'll take it
seriously you know our members have been
suffering from pay cuts for effectively
last decade they're seeing a service
that's been downtrodden they're
demoralized and ultimately many of them
are watching patients dying needless
deaths and ultimately it has to change
this isn't an action we take likely
there hasn't been an ambulance dispute
for a major ambulance dispute for over
30 years but frankly no one is listening
and they need to see a change
are you considering coordinated strike
action like other unions are
yeah well we will be talking to the
other unions we know that the nurses
have got their first ballot in over 100
years we know that our colleagues in
unite in unison are currently delivering
ballots so we'll be looking to make sure
this has the Maximum Impact we will be
making sure that emergencies are covered
but ultimately the government need to
listen we need to see our members terms
and Ambitions improved they need to deal
with 135 000 vacancies in the NHS and
they need to make sure that the public
across the country are ultimately
protected and that's not happening we
know that potentially ambulance workers
are thing here going on strike is the
same time as nurses as well I mean would
you support a general strike
well I mean ultimately that's not on the
agenda at the moment
um but I think you know right across the
Public Services right across the private
sector we're seeing a working people in
this country who've worked all the way
through the pandemic delivering
essential Services we're seeing their
pay being cut after 10 years of
austerity and at the moment from the
government the messages were getting
more are the same it's not acceptable
something has to change this frankly is
a cry for help and a government need to
listen the public of Britain deserves
better the NHS members deserve better
and we need to see something happen and
something happen very fast but wouldn't
a general strike be a short sharp shock
for the government I suppose is what
some of your colleagues would say I know
that several union leaders have been on
this program has said that a general
strike is the way forward I'm asking you
whether you would support that
well I think we have some of the most
restrictive industrial action laws in in
the world
um that makes it very very difficult for
that to happen legally we don't want to
leave our members in a situation where
they can be be fired effectively so at
the moment we're trying to deal with a
matter in hand and what we're talking
about is an NHS strike you know the NHS
is a backbone of Britain you know Knight
Beverly set it up so the NHS would be
there for as long as people fought for
it and that's what we're doing we're
fighting for patient safety we're
fighting for better terms and conditions
for our members and we're fighting for
the NHS that our public deserve okay I
think you're saying no to a national
strike at this stage
um I spoke to the union Unison leader
yesterday 35 turnout eight out of 200
employers meeting the turnout threshold
what was the support for a strike
amongst your members
well the support is very strong you know
as I say we have very restrictive rules
in relation to Industrial action we have
a slightly ridiculous position where we
have to rely on postal votes You know
despite the fact that the conservatives
could quite happy to have Electronics
because the male workers are on strike
that's the problem
well yeah yeah yes partially but at the
end of the day we have to ask a question
that you know when Liz truss and we saw
the disaster that happened there could
be elected by a via electronic voting we
have to ask the question why we have to
rely on quite frankly Antiquated methods
to deliver industrial action what we're
hearing loud and loudly from our members
across the country is they're not
putting up with this anymore and quite
frankly we have to reform industrial
action law we have to reform you know
even Winston Churchill talked about the
right to strike being a fundamental one
and yet we have a load of public school
boys in the uh who run the government
who quite frankly are not interested in
listening they have to start listening
to this K and this is a this is an issue
that affects every single person in
Britain you know so many of us rely on
the NHS when we call 999 speaking to
call handlers who are often paid less
than 10 pound fifty something has to
change and quite frankly we're getting
fed up of being talked to talk down to
by the government who seem completely in
the dark about the problems quite
frankly we've come to the view that they
simply don't care and this isn't good
enough it's not good enough for patience
it's not good enough okay staff it's not
good enough for anyone we pay our taxes
and we deserve better okay Mr pentagas
I've got my pen at the ready just give
me those figures if you would please for
the support for the strike
um I haven't got them off the top of my
head but our members voted they voted an
illegal ballot under very restrictive
laws ultimately passed a very highly
threshold and they have shown and
they've voted and they're going to be
supporting it and we expect a picket
line threshold we expect Mass support
the afraid where the threshold
ultimately is you have to get over 50 on
a postal ballot and as you said in the
current situation where male workers on
strike what lots of our members have
said they're working themselves you know
all hours they're doing very long shifts
supporting the people of this country
and on a high pressure
how high above 50 were you
it varied in different ambulance trusts
as I said Each one was dealt differently
and in many of them we completely
smashed that that threshold so I'll
remember when we didn't meet the
threshold were there many when you
didn't meet the show there were there
were
that that there were there were a few
they vary across the country as I said
if we went to the previous 2016 rules
then virtually every single ambulance
trust would be put out as I say you know
in 2016. how many ballot papers did you
send out how many ballot papers did you
send out uh I
I think he was somewhere in a region of
20 000 to our ambulance members and over
10 000 of them will be taking action
okay so twenty thousand you sent out how
many were returned
I haven't got those figures off the top
of my head I'm afraid
okay
um you say that patients will always
come first if there's coordinated action
of strikes by um unions in the NHS how
can how can you Safeguard
um the health of patients
well at the moment the question has to
be asked is whether the the protection
is being safeguarded currently you know
we've got ambulance workers who are
talking a 26 hour delays to get out to
people who desperately need that support
we have people literally dying on cues
outside of hospitals you know ultimately
we're watching a service be running to
the ground and our members have bravely
taken a stand that says this cannot go
on so we will be providing emergency
cover we will be speaking to the NHS
trusts about exactly what can be
delivered on that but this is about
delivering a short Sharp Shop to the
government they have a choice they can
either fund the service or they can
simply watch it with real way and what
we have to say is we deserve better
we've seen these members work all the
way through the pandemic putting
themselves and their families at Great
risk and what's the thanks they've got
further pay cuts they see mortgages go
up they're saying energy bills go up
they're seeing everything go up and they
are getting poorer and this is after 10
years of flatlining wages it's not
totally get it Mr President guess
absolutely and I'm sure a lot of my
viewers this morning will be saying you
know we went on the steps to clap for
carers and look at the position that
they're in we're hearing that some
nurses have to use food backs I'm sure
other NHS workers find themselves in the
same position but I suppose my question
to you is that you cannot guarantee the
welfare of patients if there's
coordinated action
um as because of a lot of unions who are
working with the NHS kind of you you
just can't
well no but we can't guarantee that
safety at the moment as I was saying GK
one third of our members in the
ambulance service believe that they have
been involved in a delay that has led to
a patient dying so this isn't a
situation where this is a service that
runs perfectly well this is a service
that's dying on its feet and our members
are actually standing up and you know in
the public of Britain should support
them this is a matter of a life or death
situation they don't want to strike they
do their job because they want to save
lives you know they work extremely hard
often for wages that a lot of people
wouldn't get out of bed for and
ultimately you know they are saying
enough is enough it's time for them to
take action this is the one thing that
they can do to try and improve patient
safety to try and improve the terms and
conditions to try and deal with 135 000
vacancies that we have among a service
that we rely on you know I was born in
an NHS hospital I've had relatives die
in an HS hospital it's there for us and
at the moment there's a big question
about whether that's foreign
and you know I've had relatives dying in
NHS hospital but I wouldn't want a
relative of mine to die in an NHS
hospital because there was coordinated
strike action by the unions
no and no one wants that at the moment
but what I also wouldn't want is a
relative of mine to die in an HS
hospital because it's being denied
funding because they're staff shortages
because there's delays because
ultimately the staff are demoralized
overworked and tired and what we're
saying is that has to be addressed okay
it's really good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for putting the case
this morning for your union thank you